Oh, you to look at some deserve at scale submissions.
You guys talking about these guys sent me some deserve at scale stuff about
people who are high on the [inaudible] deserve it, deserve it scales so drunk.
Um, let's look at some of these here.
I haven't looked at these yet. Wow.
Oh, that's so funny. Dude.
Guy gets so mad walking at the person. I don't know why.
And he's so mad and he walks into a pole. Looks like Santa,
and he's so mad.
So this is the classic example of someone taking something out on something.
Someone, because something else happened. He's mad.
This guy's walking across the car.
He's yelling at the guy and he walks into a pole and after walks into a pole,
he gets even more mad at the guy said this play.
Wow, love it.
I love it.
You're such a ho. I love it.
How come they can make music like that is such a, uh,
I love it. And they'll
all do it. Oh, you have you seen this one?
I caught up with Chelsea and Michael who are jogging by and we're nice to just
stop for a quick second.
Of all, this is already so boring.
Like don't catch up with anyone jogging, you know? Oh,
go, you got, Oh, you got joggers opinions. Oh, hold up.
Hey joggers, what do you think?
How boring are joggers? So it's so snowy here.
And this is the Metro weather somewhere. WSU, Vancouver, Vancouver,
all Saturday events are canceled.
So we're catching up with some joggers and they're still jogging even though
it's snowing.
So the deserve at scale is at an all time high because
don't jog when everything is canceled because of weather.
But these people are like, you know what? We've got swept up in the moment.
We're the kind of guys that, that sleep without Capitano in Italy.
We're the kind of guys that think burgers and Amsterdam are the best.
With Chelsea and Michael who were jogging by and were nice to just stop for a
quick second. And I said, what are you doing? Running?
And you're saying it was really good out.
It's the perfect texture for running very low.
You yoga teacher, dude,
are you me? You might as well have just said I don't eat meat knots.
All I talk about because you're so annoying.
The perfect texture for running the pur. First of all, honestly,
anytime someone says the word texture is Eero, unless you're a,
you lay tile, you're an. You know,
the perfect texture for my guests is the perfect texture for face planting
too. Cause I have a feeling that's, what's gonna be.
The perfect texture for running very low impact. And it's dry.
Let me guess if the cook agrees, let's see your feet, don't get wet.
What have you seen while you've been out running? It's been a lot of fun.
There's a lot of other runners and more skiers than runners. For sure.
I think they've got a little bit of the advantage with the whole stride and
glide thing, but it's too nice to not be out here. Yeah.
Dude, it's snowing.
It's snowing, man.
It's incredible though. Just to see even people still on their bicycles. Yeah.
I don't know how they do it with the bikes like breaking.
Well, you're doing it running. Just go inside, man. Watch Seinfeld.
Well, at least we can control, you know, worst case.
We can just fly right through a stop sign and.
This case, dude,
this guy it's so high on the dessert scale because it's snowing and he's talking
about,
they're talking about how the texture's good for running and they want to be,
you know what, it. We're not going to let the weather hold us back.
Even though it's not safe to do it.
And also he's being so cocky about it. I mean,
listen to the saying, look, you know.
No how they do it with the bikes, like breaking, at least we can control,
you know, worst case. We can just.
The bikers a little bit of, Hey man, got to give them credit.
Even though he thinks deep down, he's getting the credit. You know what I mean?
Cause it's like, he he's like,
let me just like pass off the credit to the bikers who really are the heroes.
This guy knows people. The, the,
the people who are like the, the followers are going to be like, well,
you know, but you're the real hero. You don't even use a bike though.
I'll tell you. And that's the hard thing.
And this guy knows that those people are out there.
So this is their dessert scale is off the charts, dude.
Their bicycles. Yeah. I don't know how they do it with the bikes.
Because then he thinks we're going to think, well,
we don't know how you do it without the bikes.
Well, at least we can control. You know,
I can just fly right through a stop sign and we'll be okay.
Cause we're pretty visible at night. I surprise you the snow,
this much of it. I think when we woke up this morning,
we were definitely surprised by how much there was,
there was sort of joking that it was a nice dusting,
but the reality is is this is a, this is a real chunk of snow getting hurt.
Let me just tell you, let me just ask you right now.
If you're listening to this right now and not watching it on the video.
Guess if these people are white.
In France money. Yeah, no kidding. Yeah. We're both California kids.
So we haven't had many snow days in our lives. This is pretty exciting.
We'll go ahead and keep it on the run. I started to have kept you,
but I appreciate you guys talking with us. All right. Thanks.
Can we seen a lot of people out here? Like you said, running sledding,
just enjoying it. Oops. That can happen. Unfortunate.
And she ate.
Oops. That can happen, unfortunately. Ah, okay. Thanks scientists.
So we've seen a lot of.
People out here, like you said, running sledding, just enjoying it. One thing.
Oops. That can happen. Unfortunately.
Dude, the background is so sad. I feel bad actually,
because she looked like she hurt. I wish he fell.
I don't like when the girl falls.
Kept you, but I appreciate you guys talking with us. All right. Thanks.
So we've seen a lot of people out here, like you said, running sledding,
just enjoying it. One thing, oops. That can happen.
I love the well of course, behind the oops in the,
in the newscaster. Oops, oops.
And that can happen. Knew these people were idiots and you can tell,
listen to that. Oops. How much she knew.
Sorry to have kept you, but I appreciate you guys talking with us. All right.
Thanks. So we've seen a lot of people out here, like you said, running sledding,
just enjoying it. One thing. Oops. That can happen.
God, you know that hoops is great. Let's look at you. Two comments.
One of my favorite things. Oh look, how do you like the texture now? Siddiq.
Oh wow. People are crazy. Huh? Camera man is. Oh gee.
For continuing to film them. It's actually funny because I did think about like,
well that's odd how he's filming him for so long.
Dry snow. You know.
When people say dry snow, Hey, do you know what snow is? Water.
Here's another one deserve at scale. Let's see what this one is.
I've never seen this one. Okay. Guy is running full speed at night.
First of all,
never run full speed at night because you can't say all right.
Who running? I mean, this guy is running full speed.
Oh he's streaking in the quad or he's at school.
Right in the glass. Like he's a Yorkie right in the glass.
Like he's a dog. Like you said.
Go.
Oh, full speed. I had into the glass look. I mean,
you know, what's, so not funny. Streaking you just like.
Yeah.
The people in the court it's like a tennis court.
He was going to try and run through the tennis court.
But there was glass and people in there were just like, what the is this doing?
Like, so didn't give him a reaction. Wow.
What's your.
Well, I already love this one. Oh wow. Okay. So when someone thinks they're bad,
that's the best. So this guy
Camera on him just filming his buddy walking
And he's dancing a little bit. Oh no. Does he get hit by a car? Oh,
I can't watch this.
I mean, he's doing like dancing.
Okay. Don't watch that one because the guy maybe died.
Hey Debbie didn't die. But also don't look at that one. That one was so,
they gotta be funny guys. I mean, w who you say?
I think long and hard do what you gotta do to make it go right in the bad guy.
Oh, I've seen this one. She rockets the thing she's pulling back.
The catapult thing. It goes right in the guy's face.
Her face. I'm not kidding.
Like, why is this thing taking watermelons?
Catapulting them across.
Super close. Right in the kisser show that night who's boss.
Oh my God. Right in the kisser show that guy. Who's the boss.
Who's boss flies forward. Comes back, smashes her in her own face. Kay.
So she died. Hey guys, don't send the ones where they die.
Okay. Why didn't nobody react to it? They just went, Ooh.
Hey, the girl died. Yeah. Deserve it skills.
Wow. Those are, I don't know, man.